تحيه طيبه مشاهدي
الكرام لماذا يتجاهل بشار الاسد وابواق
محنه 15 مليون نازح ولاجئ سوري يشغلون
العالم لماذا لم يذكرهم بشار بكلمه تعاطف
واحده في كل خطاباته
السرياليه لماذا وصل الامر بمؤيد الى وصف
نصف الشعب السوري المشرد بالعملاء
والخونه اليس لان بشار وايران يحاولان
افراغ سوريا من سكانها وتغيير تركيبتها
السكانيه لماذا لم نرى علويا واحدا في
مخيمات اللجوء او باحثا عن ماوى في عرض
البحار اليس لانه موكل بمهمه تشريد
السوريين يتساءل
ضيفنا الم يعترف بشار الاسد نفسه بان
سوريا ليست لمن يحمل جنسيتها بل لمن يدافع
عنها الا يعني ذلك انه باع لقطعان
المرتزقه الذين استورده للدفاع عن عرشه
الطائفي المتهاوي
الا يتشدق بشار بانه فاز في الانتخابات ب
90% من اصوات
السوريين اليس ال 15 مليون نازح ولاجئ
سوريين لكن في المقابل الم يتهم رئيس
الوزراء السوري قبل ايام اوروبا باساءه
معامله اللاجئين السوريين الم تجتمع
الحكومه لمناقشه ازمتهم اليس المشردون
السوريون ضحيه التامر الدولي والعصابات
الارهابيه التي تعيث خرابا ودمارا في
سوريا الم يقل الرئيس الروسي قبل ايام ان
السوريين ضحيه داعش واخواتها وليس النظام
ماذا يمكن ان تقدم الحكومه السوريه
للمشردين اكثر مما فعلت اليست مشغوله
بمواجهه اكثر من 100 فصيل ارهابي على ارض
سوريا اليس الذين يغرون السوريين باللجوء
هم الذين يفرغون سوريا من طاقاتها البشريه
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على لؤي
المقداد مدير مؤسسه مسارات وعلى الدكتور
الاكاديمي وفيق ابراهيم نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان النظام
السوريه يحاول افراغ سوريا من ملايين
السوريين المعارضين
94.1 نعم 5.9 لا لؤي المقداد لو بدات معك
بهذه النتيجه
وب تناول او تعامل النظام السوري
و وسائل اعلامه مع محنه اللاجئين السوريين
وهي ليست جديده في واقع الامر بل تعود الى
بدايات الثوره يعني لو نظرنا الى هذا
النظام او الى هذا الاعلام في الوقت الذي
نرى كل الاعلام العالمي يركز على محنه
اللاجئين على الحدود وفي البحار الذين
يموتون في البحار نرى التلفزيون السوري
يقدم برنامجا كيف تلد انثى الواط واط اه
كيف تفسر مثل هذا الانكار الفاضح لازمه
تؤرق العالم يعني بدايه انا اعتقد ان
النسبه هي تعادل نسبه الشعب السوري يعني
هي نسبه الشعب السوري باعتبار ان بشار
الاسد يعتبر ان الشعب السوري هو 6% الذين
يؤيدونه يعني دكتور فيصل يجب ان نعود الى
بدايه الثوره في سوريا منذ اليوم الاول
للثوره في سوريا بشار الاسد اعتمد نظريه
تقول ان هناك مئات الالاف من السوريين او
ملايين السوريين انا لا اريدهم منذ اليوم
الاول لا اريدهم لا اريدهم يعني بقول لك
اكثر من هيك منذ اليوم الاول للثوره منذ
بدايات الثوره في الشهر اعتقد 6 او 7/2011
زار داوود اوغلو وقان حينها وزيرا
الخارجيه بشار الاسد وقدم له مبادره للحل
في سوريا بشار الاسد كان جوابه واضح وهذه
الروايه الدقيقه للمساله اننا استلمنا
سوريا 7 ملايين سوري نعيدها 7 ملايين سوري
قال بالله بالضبط استلمنا سوريا 7ب ملايين
سوري نسلمكم اياها 7 ملايين سوري او
نسلمها للسوريين 7 يا سيدي اليوم داوود
اغلو عايش يصغى منصب رئيس الحكومه التركيه
وبشار الاسد جوز اسمع عايش كلهم موجودين
ينكر بشار الاسد انه لم يقل هذا الكلام
لداوود اوغلو وكان حينها قال له نحن
استلمنا سوريا 7ب ملايين
وسنسمع نعيدها 7عه ملايين يعني هو عرفان
حاله انه سارق قطعه الجبنه ثم انتقلنا الى
المربع الثاني اللي بشار الاسد اعتمده ان
هناك مئات الالاف او ملايين السوريين لضد
ضدي هؤلاء نعتبرهم مع عيالهم مع اصدقائهم
مع اقربائهم بيئه حاضره للارهاب لديهم
مشكل تربوي يعني مشكل هو اعتبرهم بلا
تربيه وبلا اخلاق ويجب قتلهم ببساطه بدا
المشروع من هنا بدا مشروع التهجير من هنا
بشار يعني هو مشروع تهجير دك بالدكتور
بالنهايه بشار الاسد ما يفعله اليوم هو
يستنسخ التجربه الصهيونيه عند بدايه انشاء
اسرائيل اتى اتت التجربه الصهيونيه
بعصابات الهاجانا بشار الاسد اليوم اتى
برابين جديد برابين بال بالتجربه
الصهيونيه كان هو قائد الميداني لعصابات
الهجانه اليوم اتى برابين جديد اسمه حسن
نصر الله هو رابين لبنان الذي اتى به بشار
الاسد واتى ب عصاباته لافراغ سوريا من
شعبها رابين كان يصرح حينها بانها حين
نقتل ونهجر ونشر قريه او ضيعه او مكان
الفلسطينيين لنلق درس لقريه اخرى لتهاجر
اليوم اذا من اليوم الاول من البيضاء من
اليوم الاول من احداث البيضاء وبانياس
والقبر ودعس عروس الناس وتدبيس ويا مدري
مين ويا تارات مدري شو ما بده
ين رفع رفع يا حسين على مساجد على مساجد
القصير وتدعس على راس الناس ويا علي و ابو
حيدر كان ضمن اطار واضح تهجير طبعا هلا هو
شو المشكل سيخرج الان بعض الموتورين
والابواق تقول لك عم يحكي طائفي طيب يا
عمي هل اللي بيقول انه اليوم في ذبح طائفي
بصير هو طائفي انا اوصف ما يحصل يعني
اليوم انا اذا بقول بشار الاسد يهجر السنه
بتحب اقول لك لا عم يهجر العلويه كون ما
عم بحكي طائفي من يهجر اليوم في سوريا هم
فئه معينه هم معرضين نظام الاسد بالتاكيد
يعني اليوم انا بعطيك بالارقام ان هناك
فعليا اكثر من نصف الشعب السوري اصبح
مهجرات لها ان تغادر سوريا ان تخرج من هذه
البلاد وان يحال مكانها يعني في اعاده
توزيع ديموغرافي هلا بتقول لي بده يجيب
الايراني بده يجيب الروسي بده يجيب حزب
الله ما بعرف بده يفضيها يقعد فيها هو
ماهر واسمى وبشرى و ورامي مخلوف يلعبوا
شده ويحكوا على تليفونات سيرتين ما بع بس
هناك مشرو طئ هناك مشروع افرا واعاده
توزيع
للرا تويع ديموغرافي الرا السيه مشرو دور
كيف ترد هنا مشرو فيقع الامر يعني ماحدث
الان تهجير وتشريد للسوريين بالملاين
وخارجيا ليس مرد يعني نتيجه حرب نتيجه راع
هو موضوع اليوم الاول للثوره وكيف ترد ع
ما قاله بشار الاسد بالضبط لرئيس الوزراء
التكي
اولا يعني هذا الكلام يعني هو عم
يقوله لا يقوله الرئيس بشار الاسد سوريا
ليست قطع جبنه سوريا وطن تفاعلت على ارضه
مجموعات بشريه وشكلوا انظمه مشتركه للعيش
الصراع في سوريا ليس مذهبيا الصراع في في
سوريا بس خلينا بموضوع المهجرين ونجي
بعدين بس فقط يعني كمان لانه مش موضوعنا
حسن السيد حسن الصه لم يدخل الى سوريا الا
بعد تسع غارات اسرائيليه وانت كنت ساكت
بعد اشتباكات مع مختلف الدول اللي صار
تدعي انه هي فاته دخل حسن وص الله بعد سبع
عربيات مفخخه عليه في الضحيه الجنوبيه
ماشي دكتور بس كي لا نخرج على الموضوع
خليني بموضوع اللاجئين هو هو لب الموضوع
هو لب الاخبار في العالم هناك فارق بين
المهجرين والنازحين الازمه السوريه ابتدات
اكيد بالمناطق التي حدثت فيها انتقل الناس
من منطقه الى منطقه هناك تهج داخلي يا
استاذ لي التشجير الداخلي 3 مليون الى 4
مليون تركوا مناطق المعارضه واتوا الى
مناطق النظام السوري مناطق الس 3 مليون
اجوا من مناطق الرقه وزور كل مناطق وادلب
اجوا قعدوا بمناطق النظام السوري اليوم
النظام السوري يعني يضم بين 65 الى 70%
ممن بقي من سوريين في سوريا هذ هذه
المعلومات موثقه ومؤكده هلا هذا التهجير
كما وصفته جريده لوموند في عددها كانون
الثاني 2014
قالت انه تهجير متعمد قامت به مدروس من
اجزه استخباريه في السعوديه وتركيا واجزه
غربيه وهذا موثق وبعطيك را من العدد مقال
سبع صفحات قالت انه تهجير هجروا السوريين
بالقوه واعدو في بلدان الجوار لاستثمار
الوقود في المنظمات السلفيه بسعر رخيص
والدليل على ذلك انهم يعني لم لم لم
يرسلوا مساعدات الى هؤلاء الى هؤلاء
المهجرين الا بمعدل واحد على خس مما كانوا
قد وعدوا به فكان ان ذهب هؤلاء الى
المنظمات التكفيريه ب 20 دولار وب 30
دولار شنم انا اتكلم بشكل علمي هذا الكلام
موجود في اللوند وبعطيك العدد تبعها موجود
باللون مو يعني
شكلد واحده اكيد ار اكيد ار اكيد ار اكي
بس عفوا منهم الذين هجروم بس منهم قلت
هجروم ما قلتلي من قلت لي هجروم يفهم مين
انا قلت في ح
هجرو المنظمات التكفيريه القصد طبعا
وهجرهم الجيش الحر وهجرهم وحتى يمكن الجيش
السوري و عم يخصف تهجروا قعدوا ببلدان
الجوار ما بدك تبك بدك تعتمد يا المخابرات
السعوديه وفرنسيه الجيش السوري ماطه بجير
وليد عمليات عسكريه حدثت في هذه المناطق
عملت المخابرات السعوديه والفرنسيه مش هيك
لما راحوا التهجير بخطه انه هجرهم طب
الجيش السوري
بك اكيد كل الكلمه يا دكتور
بكرت الناس تلبيه لخطه مخابراتيه ماخبر
قعدوا بالاردن وتركيا روح شوف شو عملوا
80% من القوه التكفيريه موجوده بسوريا
كلها من هذه المخيمات وبعدما تحول التهجير
الى ياس ياس من امكانيه تغيير النظام تحول
الى نزوح والمؤسف ان الذي يدير النزوح
اليوم هو انا خليه كفي مجك الذي يدير
النزوح اليوم هو نفسه الذي ادار التهجير
روح شوف بازمير بشوارع ازمير روح شوف كيف
ينقلون السوريين زفات وحانا انا معك نعم
هناك مؤامره على الكيان السياسي السوري
وليس على النظام السياسي السوري بس بس هي
النقطه بدي اوضحها الكيان السياسي السوري
مهدد اليوم لان هناك قوى تريد تقسيمه
وشرمته منها اسرائيل منها امريكا منها
منها تركيا منها الكثير من الدول اما ان
تقول لي انه ب نستورد لنا شي 10 مليون
ايراني ونجيبه على المنطقه لم يسبق لايران
ان فعلت ذلك واذا فعلت فانا ادينها مثلك
انا ادين المرجعيات الدينيه الاسلاميه بك
بكاملها من سنه وشيعه لانها لم تاخذ موقفا
مساله النازحين كان يجب عليها ان تكون مثل
بابا الكاثوليك الذي قال على كل المؤسسه
الكاثوليكيه ان تستقبل النازحين انا اديم
هذا العربي تبع جامعه الدول العربيه الذي
قال ان مشكله النازحين اكبر من امكانيه
الجامعه العربيه هؤلاء لا هؤلاء يجب علينا
ان نتوجه لكي نج حلا كيف اولا بدي اشكر
الدكتور على صدقه وصراحته بمساله انه هناك
ملايين السوريين ياسوا من تغيير النظام
فهاجروا يعني هو يقول الان ان بشار الاسد
مارس
القطل انت يا دكتور عم تقول لي هنا هلا في
نزوح نزح من ياس من تغيير النظام ياس كان
العوده ياس لحد الد ما في 14 مليون ياسوا
من تغيير بشار لانه دبحه هاجروا هيك قلت
مش
انا انت
قلت مش هذا الموضوع تفضل هناك ملايين
السوريين ياسوا من تغيير النظام مارس
عليهم النظام هذا الكم الهائل من القتل
والاجرام فغادروا هلا هو عم يقول انه هول
التنظيمات الارهابيه انا اليوم بدي افهم
وهي دكتور ارقام يعني هي ارقام الا خلينا
نشوف الارقام هلا هيدي هي هيدي ارقام الام
المتحده تفضل تفضل الا المتحده تفضل
ال999 سوري مسجل في تركيا نعم 7 ملاين
و600 ال مشرد في الداخل السوري مليون و113
ال في لبنان 132000 في
مصر مليون و400 ال في الاردن هدول كلهم
هجرتهم داعش هجرتهم المعارك القتاليه و
معناها هناك معارك قتاليه على كامل
الاراضي السوريه طبعا طبعا معناها بشار
الاسد لو مدرب فريق فوتبول وصار له خمس
سنين معارك قتاليه عم يخسرها وداعش
والتنظيمات التي تصفها بالمتطرف سيطرت على
كل هذه المساحات يجب عليه ان يرحل لو في
ذره اخلاق من ير اذا بتريد ما قاطعك اذا
بتريد ماط لا هلا هون شو في نقطه هلا يا
دكتور انا بحترم انك دكتور جامعه بس بدك
تقدر انه نحن مو طلاب عرفت بدك تقدر مني
طالب يعني بدك اعم نتناقش عم تعطيني
محاضره عظيم انت وانا عم بحكي الله يخليك
انت وانا عم بحكي قلت لي ما تعطي انت هون
لما عم تقول انه بشار الاسد حجر بسببه او
هذه المعارك القتاليه حجر بسببها هؤلاء
الملايين وان هذه التنظيمات قد احتلت
خليني اقول كل هي المناطق وبشار الاسد اذا
هوس الرئيس لا يصلح لان يكون رئيس لو هو
مدير مطعم وفشل خمس سنين بكره وبيفتح شغله
بيفهم فيها يروح يلاقي له شي شغله هو واسم
يحل عنا اما ان تقول بانه خمس سنين من
التدمير والتهجير وكل هذا وبعدين بتطلع
القصه انه والله بشار الاسد ما دخله مين
دخله انا مين بده يدخله انا دكتور خليني
اقول لك شاهدت حالات خلال الاسبوع الماضي
واللي قبله ب دول اوروبيه كنت فيها ام
مئات الالاف من السوريين الذين المهجرين
من المنا كنت انت كنت انت قادم الان من
النمسه ها من النمسه بين النمسه والمج
تفضل مئات الالاف من السوريين الذين
ينزحون من مناطق سيطره النظام واللي بيقول
لك غير هيك والله العظيم قسما بالله عم
يكذب عليك والله العظيم الحلاق وبياع
الموبايلات وتبع المطعم والمراه اللي
ساكنه بالمهاجرين جنب بيت بشار الاسد اللي
هربت لانه بس ساكنه جنب بيت بشار اخذوا له
زوجها واولادها لهالمرحله كله ضب اغراضه
ومشي هلا بتقول لي عمليات قتاليه ونستخدم
مصطلحات كبيره اللي بدك اياه بس انا عم
اقول لك اليوم انا شفتهم بعيوني بالنمسا
وبالمجد وبماني وبال الاطار بدي اشكر
السوريين السوريين اللي للاسف في واحد
[__] اسمه سفير بالنمسا وواحد ندل اسمه
سفير بالمانيا عرفت هدول معتبر حالهم
سفراء سوريا لم يكلفوا خاطرهم ان يزوروا
محطه
قطار 73 سوري قتلوا في شاحنه ما طلب سفير
بشار الاسد في النمسا السفير الموجود من
الحكومه النمساويه نتائج التحقيق في
سوريين عم يطلعوا بسياراتهم عم يلفوا
سندويش للناس بايديهم عم يستنوا الناس
محطات قطار مشان يساعدوهم من تدعي انه
رئيس لم يسال عن واحد منهم عن واحد عن طفل
عن طفل بشار الاسد لم يصدر بيان ليسال شو
اسم الطفل اللي مزتو على شط البحر بتركيا
ما سال لانه هذا مانه رئيس فتقول لي رئيس
الله يخليك اذا واحد سعودي بياكل كف ب
بلندن السفير السعودي بروح بزوره واحد
قطري بيتسمى بمستشفى مادري وين بروح
السفير القطري بزوره نحن مئات الالاف من
السوريين على الانين على الحدود ما في
سفير بلا كرامه حمل حاله نزل على الحدود
ليسال وينهم سالت وزاره الخارجيه
الالمانيه قلنا لهم اخي وين مسؤولين بشار
الاسد ع ما يحصل قال ما حدا تواصل معنا
بهذا الخصوص السلطات النمساويه قدمنا له
رسميا قلنا له نتائج تح هل سلمت الى
النظام قال لم يطلبها النظام ولم يطلبها
سفير النظام الموجود في نص بنص فينا قاعد
عم يكتب تقارير بالناشطين السوريين هذا
اللي بيشتغلوا فالله يخليك لما بدك تدافع
عن حدا يعني بس احكي شيء يرضي ضميرك ويرضي
الناس اللي انت عم تقولك عنق هذه النقطه
اللي بدي اسالك عنها دكتور بس جاوبني
عليها كم خطاب القى الرئيس السوري حتى
الان العديد من
الخطابات هل سمعت بشار الاسد في يوم من
الايام يقول كلمه تعاطف واحده يتيمه مع
اللاجئين او النازحين السوريين لم نسمعه
يوما يقول قلوبنا مع ابنائنا المشردين
الذين تاكلهم الحيتان والاسماك في عرض
البحار دقيقه لم ي لم يرتبه اليهم احد في
الوقت الذي انا بعيد عليك السؤال هل يعقل
في الوقت الذي ترى كل تلفزيونات العالم
تركز على محنه اللاجئين السوريين حط على
التلفزيونات السوريه اما مسلسلات او برامج
طبخ او برامج عم كيف تلد الحيه او زنبوط
الحنفوش على نفسك يا بشار الاسد ولك ما
بتستحي ما فيش عندك اولاد ولك ولك ما
بتستحي على حالك ولك شوف الناس اللي عم
بتموت ولك اطلع احكي لك كلمه هذول سوريين
يا ابن ال 60 الف كذاك بقولوا لك السوريين
لك انا بدي اسالك انت كيف بتشوفها لك ولا
مره حكى عنهم ولا مره جابهم بيطلع يتفلسف
الشنف وطه الفلسفات المحمولات لك روح ولك
ما بتستحي على حالك لك ما عندك ضره اكرام
ب انا عم
هذا 17 مليون سوري ما انذكر مره حده
بتلفزيونات يا زلمه هلا اكيد عم ينذكر بس
يبدو انه
اهتماماتك اهتماماتكم موجهه نحو محطات
ثانيه انا متاكد من الناحيه الانسانيه
الرئيس الاسد متعاطف مع كل السوريين وانا
متاكد
اكثر متعاطف مع سوريا بوصفه هو اجنبي
بوصفه ايران يعني الشعب السوري الشقيق
شلون يعني متعاطف معه بشار بشار الاسد
رئيس الشعب السوري على اساس خلي دقيقه بس
يا اخي سالتك سؤال ليش ما بع سفير يا
استاذ ل ليش ما بعد سفير عم حطط عم تروح
علىق كثير ضعيفه معلش خ ضعيفه هي القطه
يحكي
تضلني انا
بظا السني عليها جاوبوا عليها طيب وين الس
السفراء
السور يا ليش ما بينزل محطه قطار اذا
راحوا او لا بس انا بقوللك ما راحوا انت
عم تحكي رايك
هحكي بمع النظام السوري يتعرض لحمله
اسرائيل والاردن وتركيا وهلا عم يتعرض
اكثر لغارات بريطانيه وغرا فرنسيه النظام
السوري قصك داعش النظام السوري انا عم
بحكي انه هناك تدخل شون س من عشرات
البلدان يعني مؤسسه صوفن بامريكا عدت 81
دوله عم تقوللي انت هلا نحن نريد ان نصل
الى نتيجه النازحون السوريون ماسات كبرى
لكنها ليست مسؤوليه النظام السوري النظام
السوري يتبناها يتعامل معها لو كان لديه
قدره كيف اعلاميا بس اعلاميا خع انا متاكد
ان قسم من النازحين ترك مناطق النظام لان
المناطق النظام معطله بالقصف والضرب والى
اخره صار في فقر بسوريا هذا الفقر ادى
بنزوح الكثير من السوريين يعني ما ما بد
شي النزوح السوري اليوم مسا عبد الرحمن
الراشد بعدد البارح الشرق الاوسط يتهم دول
الخليج يقول انه دول الخليج لم تفعل ما
بيسعى لمعالجه هذا الامر بتيجي انت بت
بتقوللي غير هيك هذا عبد الرحمن الراشد
بالشرق الاوسط شوك غير هماس قال يجب على
دول الخليج ان تساعد اكثر لضب عمليه الزوح
وعدم السماح بهذا الزوح
الكبير بس دكتور بس مشان تروح الفكره بس
مشان تروح الفكره وصلت فكرتك بس انا
بدي اناف انا عمكي لاجين سعوديين ولا
سوريين خليني اكملك لا لؤي خليني خليني
اسالك مشان ضل طيب ب سؤال عندما تهجر اكثر
من مليون مسلم سني من حمص مدينه حمص سني
ها ما ليك ليش عم تقول لي ليش يا رطي بدي
اسالك مين اللي ظل بحمص العلويه العلويه
اللي ظلوا بحمص بدي اتحداك بس بدي اسالك
عندما تهجر مليون مسلم سني من حمص لا كان
في داعش ولا كان حدا سامع بداعش ولا من
يحزن انا بدي انا بدي اتفق معك داعش اللي
هجرت السوريين ماشي داعش هي المجرم الاولى
والاخيره بما انه داعش هجرت السوريين
لماذا لا يتعاطف نظام بشار الاسد وابواق
الاعلاميه وحلفائه مع الذين هجرتهم هذه
الارهابيه داعش في مخيمات اللجوء في في
الاردن في تركيا في داخل سوريا على الحدود
مع النمسه على كذا على كذا يا رجل يا رجل
عاده يضيع مواطن لاي بلد في اي عالم تتاهب
الحكومه باكملها 17 مليون سوري لم يا رجل
هل تعلم ماذا يدعونهم الان فوت على صفحات
مؤيدي النظام كيف يصفون المشردين
والنازحين عملاء وخونه واولاد كذا هل يعقل
17 مليون سوري عملاء حضرت برنامج على
التلفزيون السوري عم يحكي عن نازحين اهل
سوريا واحباب سوريا عمره ما عملوا برنامج
امبارح بلشوا بس طلعنا الدعايه امبارح
امبارح بالليل عمو برنامج بعد ما طلعت
دعتنا عم تعمل طريقه اعلاميه ذكيه بتشت
وال انا عم اقوللكم شغله اساسيه ما يحدث
في سوريا اليوم كارثه كبرى على كل
السوريين المساله ليست علويه وليست سنيه
لو كان الرئيس الاسد يقاتل بالعلويين فقط
لكنه يقاتل بالسوريين لا ولا يقاتل
بالانيه
والروس
اس معلش اذا بتد دكتور
هذا اذا بتلا انا بدي اسالك مثل ماال مثل
ما سال مثل ما سالت ل هناك نقطه قال هناك
نقطه قال الدكتور انا بدي اسالك بس خليني
اكمك الك الفكره يا سيد لؤي سيد لؤي لماذا
لم ترد على هذه النقطه ان ملايين السوريين
فعلا ذهبوا الى مناطق النظام لانها تدار
بطريقه افضل
ولانها هناك نوع من الحياه هناك بنيه
تحتيه الى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام الامر
الاخر الحكومه السوريه يعني لنكن واقعيين
ماذا بامكان هذه الحكومه او هذا النظام
الذي يتعرض ل حمله مؤامره كونيه دوليه في
عشرات لا بل مئات الفصائل التي تقاتل على
ارض سوريا شو بده يلحق ليلحق كمان يعني
نكون واقعيين جاوبني ما بيلحق يمشي ببساطه
نظام ما عم يلحق على الفصائل اللي عم
تقاتله يمشي نظام عم يتهجي ملايين يمشي
الا اذا بدكم لا بشار الاسد هو رب وما
بصير يتحرك وتهجر شعبه وتدمر بلده وتموت
الناس وتغرق بالبحر وتموت بالكيماوي وبشار
الاسد ضل اذا كان بشار الاسد ال ثاني
اذابني على موضوع
دا دقيقه لا بدك يا اخي بك جاوبني عليها
مثل ما سالته للرجل الرئيس الروسي قبل
ايام قال بالحرف الواحد ان
السوريين ضحيه داعش واخواتها وليسوا ضحيه
النظام لا جاوبني على النقطه اعملي مقارنه
بين النظام ودا انا هنا قبل انا هنا قبل
ما افوت مساله مقارنه داعش انا بدي اسال
باعاده التعريف هل داعش ومعلش يعني بضطر
احكي شوي طائفيا هل داعش هي تنظيم علوي
ولا تنظيم سني
اذا كانت داعش تنظيم سني يجب ان يكون من
يهجر هو العلويه انا اللي شايفه انه داعش
بيهجر السني طيب خلينا داعش لا اذا بت
داعش تحتل المناطق السنيه داعش وصلت ذبحه
صحفي ياباني يا زلمه ياباني مو تايواني
يعني يعني ياباني ياباني وما عرفت تجيب
ضابط بالحرس الثوري الايراني تذبحه بدكم
تحكوا لنا طيب داعش التي تهجر هلا دكتور
بس بس مش هذا موضوع اطيني اعطيني مقارنه
عندما يقول لك الرئيس الروسي انه داعش هي
المسؤوله اعطيني مقارنه عن ماذا مسؤول
لاعش يعني اذا كان هناك بين اعداد بين
اعداد بين اعداد المهجرين 18% من المهجرين
السوريين والنازحين هم من حمص طيب اذا
هؤلاء من حمص ما في داعش طيب اذا 16% منهم
من ريف دمشق ودمشق لا في داعش لا هون ولا
هون ع يا اخي الاردن الاردن الاردن فيها
مليون و400 ال نازح هدول كلهم دمشق وريفا
ودرعا وهذه المناطق ما فيها وين داعش مين
يا عمي هي المناطق بنصره يا دوب فيها
ف ا
هون هون ه كمل كمل هذه كمل شو اعطيني
الارقام هذه الارقام مهمه جدا هي الارقام
محصله هذه الارقام تتجاوز ال 90% ما في
منا 10% فقط من المنطقه الشرقيه التي
تسيطر عليها داعش انا اقول نعم هناك نزوح
من مناطق داعش وداعش هي قوه احتلال وظلم
لكن داعش بالنتيجه هي المولود المسخ
المشوه بزواج المتعه بين النظام الا ونظام
بشار الاسد هذا منتهي دكتور هلا اذا نرجع
له انا عندي بالبرنامج انه هي 10ش مره
بطلع كل مره بدنا من اول نرجع نقول هل
بشار الاسد يقتل شعبه ام لا هل بشار الاسد
اوجد داعش او لا انا اعتبر ان
مسال بدي بس احكي عن نقطه
النزوح علما مساله اما مساله نعم هناك بعض
الاشخاص بعض الناس الذين هجرهم النظام من
حمص من حلب ورحلوا الى مناطق النظام هم
الان في ملايه بس انا بقوللك يعملهم
بلاديه اهل كل من جمهور النظام وشبيحته
يعتبرونهم بيئه حاضنه للارهاب ويعتبرونهم
ويجب اعتقالهم هلا فوتك على صفحاتهم صفحه
صفحه على صفحه كل مجرم فيهم من يقول ان
هؤلاء هم خلايا نائمه هؤلاء ارهابيين يجب
قتلهم يعني بالنتيجه دكتور حتى هذول لو مع
النظام السنه هذول يلي مع النظام لن يرضى
عنك بشار الاسد ونصر الله حتى لو اتبعت
ملتهم هذا الموضوع لازم يكون محسوم جميل
طيب ماشي انا بسالك بس هذه نقطه مهمه جدا
قل
90% من اللاجئين السوريين اللي عددهم اكثر
من 5 مليون جاؤوا من مناطق س لا لا مش
سنيه لا وجود لداعش فيها باي حال من
الاحوال جاوب لي عليه ط اول شيء داعش طيب
ليست سنيه جابني يا اخي خليني يكفي
طيب موضوعي مش داعش داعش تنظيم سلفي يعني
يعود الى ما قبل الغرور الوسطى لديه
منظومه عيش تختلف عن منظومه عيش السوريين
حتى السنه من ه يعني لما يجي داعش
ا يعني داعش م قعدت تختلف مع نظام العيس
السوري نظام العيس السوري نظام تاريخي ليش
علويه السؤال ما في حرب العلوين بعد برافو
عليك معناها اعت اعتبرت الان تعتبر ان
الحرب فقط على مناطق
الس انا عمك ليه لانه اول شي داعش لم تاتي
العلويين باعتبار انه هو ضدها هناك اجت
سللت قدمت غطاء سني طلعت بعدين معادي
للسنه ودروز وشيعه لمسيحيين كل الناس داعش
والنصره وعشرات التنظيمات الشبيهه هؤلاء
لديهم منظومه عيش مختلفه عن السوريين
السوريون رحلوا من مناطق هذه التنظيمات
لان لديهم نظام منفتح عندهم المراه والرجل
متساويان عنده عندهم نظام عايش حران انت
بتعرف متساويان بالقمع مش
بالقمع شو بدك فيها لاحن بحي موضوع
اخر لانه تقطيع
رؤوس الاسد راس
س مل ما سالت انا بدي اسالك سؤال بدي اسال
سؤال حمص الان من يسيطر
عليها مع
النظ لماذا لم يعد سكان حمص الى حمص لماذا
لا يسمح النظام لماذا لا يسمح النظام
بعوده سكان حمص الى حمص انا بدي اسالك
معلوماتك ش لانه دقيقه دقيقه لانه مع
ايران يحاولان اعاده رسم الخارطه السكانيه
في سوريا هل سمعت عن المفاوضات التي
تجريها ايران مع جيش الفتح في الزبداني
على ان ينتقل سنه الزبداني الى ادلب وياتي
شيعه الفوعه الى الزبداني طيب عند ما ترى
مثل هذه المفاوضات على تطهير عرق تطهير
مذهبي تطهير طائفي في سوريا بترجع بتقول
لي مش تهجير منظم تهجير
منظم اول شيء الايرانيون ليس لديهم مطامع
في منطقتنا الشيعه والعرب لا يستطيعون
تعبئه كل هذه المناطق التي تتكلم عنها هم
في لبنان مليون وب سوريا 50 الف يعني بدون
ما نضحك على بعضنا هذا العدد لا يغطي شيء
هلا الموضوع بالنسبه لحزب الله موضوع
سياسي خ
ال الس بسلك نقطه مرتبطه
بهلا دقيقه بغداد بغداد قبل خمس سنوات
اربع سنوات شو كانت كانت مدينه سنيه تحولت
الى
شيعيه بغداد تحولت الى شيعيه وسوريا الان
غوطه دمشق وريف دمشق يحول الى
شيعه يحول
الى كلمه صغيره رح تقول لي معك حق العراق
محكوم من السنه منذ فيصل الاول وحتى
الصدام يعني شي 150 سنه طيب يا رجل لك اذا
اج له رئيس حكومه شيعي بتهب انت
بتعطي ولا مره بالعراق ولا مره بالعراق
ولا بسوريا صار في صدامات سنيه شيعيه هي
كلها جديده ناتجه عن الحركات السلفيه التي
اتت الى هذه المنطقه انا اجد انه من
المعيب ان نصنف العربي بتصنيفه المذهبي لك
ق بالقليل يقول عنه مسلم لك هذا مسلم دسي
هذا مسلم يا رجل لك نحن نذهب الى اين نحن
ندمر بلداننا من اجل تركيا من اجل هذه
البلدان يعني انا بس بعطيك ارقام دكتور
والله انا داخلي داخلي بدك بدك تقوللي ليش
تهجروا هدول الناس ولا لا بدك تي مين
هجرهم ولا لا هجرهم داعش عندهها براميل
داعش عندها طياره نحن ما حدا اجرهم غير
انتم غير انتم رابين رس الله اللي عم تحكي
باسمه ورئيسك اللي عم تقول عنه الرئيس
بشار الاسد الرئيس المجرم بشار الاس
حر في مجال نوصل مكان ولا لا هدول الناس
بدك تي مجرهم ولا لاي يا اخي هدول الناس
داعش عندها طيارات بميل عندها سكود هي
الناس رحلت من المناطق اللي تخص براميل
بشار
الاسدس
الرئيس ا واكثر واحد بعرف بشار الاسد اكثر
من خ خ خ خ ما
بس دقيقه بس دقيقه دقيقه لا اخي
دقيقه انه هذا واحد قاتل شعبي وعم يعطي
بشار يقتل الناس انا ما بسمع حد الكلام
دكتور هذا واحد عم يعطي سكوت لبشار الاسد
لا تق لي عنده رئيس هذا ق نص السعب السوري
300 ال سوري حن 300 ال سوري 300 ال سوري
فيه 8 الف جندي بالجيش سوري فيه 100000 من
جهات جهات بدوله م بجيب لي
ارقام خلينا
نقام ن نا ر
تناء وهي من الساحل اه يعني تابعه لبشار
الاسد ماشي وكانت وزيره كانت وزيره تكتب
على صفحتها قبل ايام منى غانم الرئيسه
السابقه للهيئه السوريه لشؤون الاسره هذه
ثنين يا دكتور اسمع هذه منى غانم منى غانم
مش منى القاسم عندما كنا كانت تقول عندما
كنا نعمل على معالجه التزايد السكاني في
سوريا لم يخطر لي انهم سيقومون بذلك عن
طريق القتل والتهجير الى بلدان اخرى وشهد
شهد من اهله هي من جماعه المعارضه الوطنيه
اللي كانت عم بتقول لك عم تعترف انه والله
نحن في عمليه دكتور عمليه عمليه تهجير
منظمه في سوريا وما كنا عارفين انه رح
يعملوها عن طريق القتل والتهجير تتهم بشار
الاسد
مباشره دكتور انا م رح غير انا مرحب غير
انا م رحب بده يجاوب على هذا الكلام يا
دكتور قبل ما نط هذول ال مليون مهجر هل
هجرهم بشار الاسد ام لا لم يه هل سبب هذا
التهجير هو من اليوم الاول تبلش قص
بالناس دق بس يا جماعه خلينا شو اسمه
جاوبني على النقطه هذ بسرعه وبرجعلك
بدون ان الدول الاوروبيه فيها اقل عدد
مواليد في العالم طيب تحتاج الى نازعين
بنيه شابه بنيه الشر الاوسط بنيه شابه
ولوده الاتراك يبيعون النازحين السوريين
الى القاره الاوروبيه بيع تفضل اقول لك
هناك من يدمر سوريا الاتراك جزء من حركه
التدمير الامريكيه جزء من حركه التدمير
المعارك ستتواصل في سوريا حتى تهجير كل
سوريين سوريا تذهب الى تقسيم ونحن نقسمها
بسكاكين نقسم الناس الى سني وشيعي
و ب اسكون فخور انا بدي اساله يا دكتور
طيب يقول لك الرجل انه سوريا سكين وما
سكين اريد ان اسال هل سمعت عن هل سمعت
عن المزه الان هناك عمليات تهجير
لالاف السوريين في منطقه المزه سمعت عننا
ولا لا قال شو عاوزين يبنوا ناطحات سحاب
ايرانيه اه طيب جاوب لي اياه على هذه نقطه
هل هذا السؤال البعض يقول لك انه هذه
عمليه طائفيه البعض يقول لك لا علاقه لها
لا بالطائف ولا شيء هذه مشاريع اقتصاديه
وتجاريه ولا علاقه
العرقي الطائ هلا في ماساه بالنقاش مع
الدكتور انه اذا انت بتقول هيك معلومه وهو
موثقه معلومه موثقه انه النظام طلع شيء
اسمه مخطط تنظيمي لمدينه دمشق فيه تهجير
لمناطق معينه وفيه بناء ابراج بيعمل لك
بيعمل لك اذا لا لا لا دقيقه انا بدي
اسالك اعطيني معطياتك عن كيف يريدون اعاده
توزيع سكان دم ه المشكله بتقول له في مخطط
تنظيمي اصدره مجلس الوزراء لهد مناطق
كامله من ال 86 للشيخ سعد لداريا لدوما
لحرز واعاده اعمارها على اساس اعاده اعمار
وتسكين انت بتعرف
مين بده يجيب بده يجيب البيئه الحاضنه هي
ما عاجبته الزلمه في بيئه حاضنه هيك ماه
عاجبته بده يشيل يحط بيئه حاضنه ثانيه
يعني سوار دمشق اللي هو كان تاريخيا اذا
انت يعني اذا انت ما بتعرفه عفوا انا ابن
الشام وبعرفه بجوز انت ما بتعرفه يعني من
ال86 للسوم بريه لعش الورور لكل مناطق
اهلنا واخواتنا العلويه هذا السوار يجب ان
يتوسع ليشمل كل المناطق السنيه هلا انت
فيك طبعا ه ت اف وين معطياتك كل كلمه
بيقول لك اياها بتقول له هذا الكلام مه
مستند هذا قرار طالع مخطط تنظيمي اعاده
عمران لمدينه دمشق بتحب لو عرفان هيك كنا
جبنا لك الطابو وجبنا لك القرار كيفلا من
رئيس الوزاره بس انا ما تخيلت انه نحن
بدنا نجد حتى بانه مين العجله والدولاب
والحصان والبيضه والدجاجه المهم فهون بهذا
ضمن هذا الاطار منذ اليوم الاول يا دكتور
ونحن عم نقول في مهجرين انت بتعرف بشار
الاسد بخطابه بال 2012 عندما خرجت اول
دفعه من اللاجئين الى جسر الشهور من جسر
الشغور الى تركيا قال بشار الاسد هدول اتت
فيهم تركيا دفعت لهم مصاري طيب هل اليوم
كل شي ناس راحت على اوروبا مثل ما عم يقول
الدكتور اوروبا بد ايد عامله يعني بشار
الاسد عم يقصف ويهجر هي الناس عم ينفذ
المخططات الاوروبيه هلا فهمت هلا فهمت
خليه كمل فهمت اول الحلقه انك قلت هذا
مخطط مخابرات الاسرائيليه والسعوديه ومدري
مين وبشار الاسد عم ينفذه فهمنا هذا
الكلام ما قلت عم ينفذه بس بس انت فعليا
انت قلت مخط طهم انت بتعرف مين عم ينفه
يعني بشار ما خصه شوفلك شغله
ياما بشار الاسد يا اما بشار الاسد هو من
يصدر اوامر اطلاق النار في سوريا وقصف
الشعب السوري بالبراميل والصواريخ يا اما
بشار الاسد قاعد مع اسما عم يلعب بلاي
ستيشن ولونا او شهرزاد او حدا ثاني هو
اللي عم ياخذ القرارات يعني ما بتعرفوا
مين عم ياخذ قرار بسوريا قرار النظام
العسكري من ياخذه بشار الاسد بشتغل ترجما
محلف عند الايراني بس بعط له القرار بيجي
هيك بالايراني بترجمه وبيقول بالعربي ماذا
تريد هل بشار الاسد انا بدي اسالك سؤال يا
دكتور انت اليوم في موقع برجع بقول لك انت
اكاديمي ودكتور جامعه اذا سالك طالب من
طلابك
اشار الاسد ياخذ القرار في سوريا تما بشار
الاس اتفقنا بمثل السوريين بس يعني عفوا
حضر حضرتك حضرتك لبناني اذا بتريد ما بحقك
تقول
السور ا بتد حض حضرتك لبناني ماحق تقول
مين ممثل السوريين لانه هلا انا بقول لك
مين ممثل اللبنانيه ب هدول هدول التوتال
تبعهم 11 مليون بشار الاسد الرقم اللبناني
غلط هول نعم هذا الرقم اللبناني غط لبنان
في 2 مليون س مليون مع هول 12 مليون هذول
12 مليون عم تقول بشار الاسد ممثلهم اذا
بمثلهم وهن من محبتهم في غادر وغرقوا
بالبحر هيص انتخبوه يا زلمه انتخبوه ه
اللي بلبنان اللي بلبنان السفاره السوريه
شهدت اكبر مظاهره طواعيه بالانتخاب بتكب
بكبه هي
عنش عم يز حالهم
بالبحر يا اخي يعني ايران الكردي اول
امبارح اخذوا ابوه اخذه هو واخته وغرقهم
بالبحر من محبته بشار الاسد قالهم كرمال
بشار الاسد يغرق لانه انا بحبكم وحب
بشار الكردي دكتور هي هي من كومي من عين
العرب
دكتور بس د بس ق قبل ماط قبل قبل قبل قبل
قبل ما تختصر لي ازمه الشعب السوري طفل
شوف لقلك شغ ايران الكردي مع محبتنا
وترحمنا عليه وطفل شهيد من سوريا لكن مه
احسن من حمزه الخطيب ولا احسن من مئات
اللي ذبحهم بشار الاسد بدومه وداريا وحمص
وحرستا وبرزه انا جبت س ايه بس انتبه م
تقولي والله الان الكردي هجرته داعش بالله
جرك داعش قلك عظيم خليني اقول لك شغله اخي
ايمتى مجلس الشعب السوري بده ياخذ قرار
مثل كل الرما الا ايمتى بده ياخذ قرار
يستقبل المشردين السوريين المشردين
السوريين المهاجرين السوريين ايمتى بده
يقول بشار الاسد شو حصته من لانه فهمنا
انه المانيا حصتها 100000 والسويد حصتها
مدري قد ما بشار الاسد قد ايه حصته من
اللاجئين السوريين عندك فكره كل لاجئ ماشي
بس دكتور يا دكتور بس بس خليني اجل النقطه
خليني اج للنقطه مش انت عم تقول كلهم
انتخبوا ماشي انا بقول لك انه الذين
انتخبوا بشار الاسد في الانتخابات الاخيره
90% 88 بس دقيقه دقيقه ط ماشي ما في في
احد الاخوه نزار من الفيسبوك يقول لك معظم
رؤساء العالم بس دقيقه يا اخي دقيقه معظم
سؤال عم يسالوا الك يا زلمه معظم رؤساء
العالم يتطرقون الان لمعاناه السوريين
اللاجئين ما عدا فقط الرئيس السوري الذي
نجح باغلبيه ساحقه بانتخابات حره ونزيهه
طبعا نزيهه اخته لجوهر ب مالحه اه طيب
السؤال المطروح الان بما انه صوتوا له
صوتوا له طيب على الاقل شي مره ابن الذين
يطلع يقول انا قلبي مع هال اللاجئين طيب
السؤال الاخر السؤال الاخر انت سمعت شو
قال بخطابه الاخير بشار الاسد قال سوريا
ليست لمن يحمل جنسيتها بل لمن يدافع عنها
الا يعني ذلك انه باعها لقطعان المرتزقه
اللي جايبهم هو وايران على سوريا بقول لك
انت اذا ما بتدافع عني معناتها انت مش
سوري معناتها يعتبر كل السوريين هؤلاء
خونه وعملاء وغير
سوريين وهذا يثبت كلامه هو قال انه كل
السوريين اللي ما عم دافعوا عني مش سوريين
وهدول الناس 14 مليون خارج سوريا هو عم عم
يحكي عن عن فئه من السوريين دخلوا فييها
التنظيمات التكفيريه عم يعتبرهم غير سورين
واكيد ه يعتبروا
خل خص كوميديا بشار الاسد انه هو بيحكي
وهن بفسر له شو بص حياتك سمعت رئيس
بيطلعوا بصيروا يفسروا بعده يعني لونا
حرام بعد كل خطاب تعمل نصائح لكل
الاعلاميين بتبعت لهم اياهم انه هيك قولوا
انه هو قصده حرام هيك قصده يعني شو هزو اس
اهبل بالمره يعني لمرحله انت بدك تفسر لله
يا زلمه هو قصده شو قصده واحد قال سوريا
ليس لمن يحمل جواز سفرها انما لمن يدافع
عني خلصنا شو بدي يقوللك عمك شو
قصده اول شغله الخطوط السلفيه لا تقبل
بحدود الخطوط
السلفيه لماما بحكي الاسد عن هودي عم
يعتبر انه ه الخطوط السلفيه اللي عم تشتغل
من اجل كونفدراليه اخوانجيه او او
كونفدراليه تركيه هذه لا مكان لها في
سوريا وتاكد ان كل حركه التاريخ منذ بدايه
سوريه الاسلاميه حتى اليوم لم يستقر تنظيم
سلفي في سوريا وهلا حاليا لن يستقر نحن مع
عف بس سلفي بسما شيع متطرف مسموح شيع
متطرف اي يعني بس يعني هو انت مشتك بس سلف
حتى الشيعي المتط يعني الالوي المتطرف شو
اخبار متطرف عظ لا تقول بس السلفي لانه لن
يستقر تنظيم ولن تستقر ايران ولن يستقر
حزب حسان نصر الله شوف يا دكتور لما تقول
سلفي وانت عم تدافع عن انت عم تدافع عن
حزب انت عم تدافع عن حزب وعن ناس انت انت
دافعت عن وجود حسن نصر الله في سوريا حسن
نصر الله تقول هون حاطت يا كارل ماركس
مثلا ولا يا زينب ولا يا حسين انت ضد زينب
وحسين لا انت ضد عمر لكان انت ضد عمر وابو
بكر ليش عم تقول
سلفي انا انتقد تطرف شيعي وتطرف علوي ما
بصير انتقده لكن هو يجوز ان ينتقد عمر بن
الخطاب سلفيا عمر بن الخطاب عاهد علي ب
ابي طالب الذي كان شيعيا والحسين كان
علويا شلون يعني مسموع حسن ن الله وكيل
الحسين
و اذا قال رفع شعار الحسين
وه رسول الله لا يقاتل السورين يقاتل فئه
تقاتل السورين يقاتل م الفئه تقاتل فئه
يعني الان حسن نصر الله الموجود في كل
شوارع دمشق وفي كل شوارع حمص هو يقاتل فئه
تقاتل السوريين يعني عندما دخل الى القصير
لانه شاف طريق القدس بمر هيك من داريا
وبيطلع من حلب وبفوت من درعا هيك طريق
القدس عند حسن نصر الله لانه عنده عم عرفت
هذا السور ستعمل تعبير يا استاذ لؤ اذا
بتريد انا ما عم بستعمل تعبير مش عنك الا
اذا معتبر حالهم اولادك او اهلك او شي
مثلا بتعتبرها اهانه لك انا عم اقول لك
دكتور انا بحترمك بس انا ودي اقول عن حسن
نصر الله مجرم ماصك عم يقتل شعبي وقول
بشار الاسد جوز اسما عم يقتل الشعب السوري
ما دخلك انت الا اذا اسم مرته اسما
وصاحبته اسم ش زاد الثانيه اسم لنا الشبل
شو بدك كمان تعرف عنه المهم هلا نعرف اسم
مرته لبشار يا زمه باختصار شديد باختصار
الوقت ي انا اقول ان سوريا هي بال
السوريين وحزب الله ينسحب من سوريا ما
تطلب منه الرئيس حافظ اسد حافظ اسد ما
لهلا بك معتبر انه بشار على الارض بعرف
معك حق لانك معتبره اهبل بدك تشرحه كلامه
طيب تفضل تفضل عندما يطلب منه الرئيس بشار
الاسد او عندما تنتهي المهمه التي ذهب من
اجلها وهي مهمه الدفاع عن
سوريا بالنسبه لموضوع ايران عن خلينا
خلينا باللاجئين والله ما تبعدن كثير غدا
غدا ستر ان الدوله السوريه مهتمه
بالنازحين اكثر غ غدا
الصباح دفاع ان دفاع الدوله السوريه عما
تبقى من الارض تحت ولايتها هي اكبر دليل
على دفاعها تمسكها بسوريا وانا بسالك طيب
لماذا تنكر لماذا تنكر ان رئيس الوزراء
السوري قبل ايام شن هجوما لائع واتهم
اوروبا باساءه حقوق الانسان السوري الله
يخليك الله الله يخليك احكي بقصه جد في
حدا اسمه اب شور رئيس الوزراء السوري يا
دكتور اتهم اوروبا بالمتاجره بحق المعلم
زمته لغى اوروبا عن الخريطه وليد بلع
امريكا واكل مدري شو اسمال اقول لك شغله
لك بشار الاسد عنده نائبه اسمها نجاح
العطار بتعرف انه نائبه بشار الاسد نائب
اسم نجاح العطار شو بتشتغل بشرفك صار له
معين بالثقافه كان بالثقافه بتعرف ليش حطه
لانه بزمت الروس قالوا له تعال نحط فاروق
الش بدالك كم يوم راح حطه بالبيت وجاب
نجاح العطار ق قادي فرمي بدونس بالمكتب
واعملي تبوله والله يا اخي كاتبه كاتبه
الله شو بتكتب اسمع لقلك شو الله يوفقها
الله يوفقها اسمع لقول لك اسمع لقول لك
شغله بشار الاسد ونظامه ونظامه بكره بده
نفق على اللاجئين وحك رئيس الحكومه م يقول
دكتور فيصل انه والله رئيس الحكومه قال
هدول اللاجئين لو في كرامه ولا اخلاق ولا
شرف واحد منهم عرف كان طلع برلمان
برلمانات اوروبا كلها اجتمعت وقالت هي
حصتنا من اللاجئين وهي الم البرلمان
السوري لم يقل هذه حصتنا ما قال يا سوريين
ارجعوا هي ارضكم ما قال يا سوريين ليش عم
تهربوا مني امبارح امبارح بالل امبارح
بالليل ف عليها امبارح بالليل امبارح
باللك في سوريين ما بدك تقبل لا امبارح
ولاول امبارح يا رجل منطقع بتجي بقتلك انا
بجي بقتلك انا بتيجي بتهرب انت وانا بجي
بقوللك بعد ما تهرب انت ع ليش انت انت ليش
هربت مني انا كنت بس عم بقتلك قلك واحد من
الشباب شو قاللي واحد من الشباب محطه
القطار بفينا بتعرف شو قاللي قت ليش طلعت
الشب عم 18 سنه قال لي عندي حلين قسما
بالله قال لي عندي حلين يا بقعد بالشام
عرفت وبده يقتلني بشار الاسد او يعتقني او
يعمللي شيء يا بدي اطلع بهب حر احتمالي
20% قلت له على احتمال 20% بتطلع قال لي
ايه بطلع على احتمال 20% لانه بالشام 100%
بالش بده يقت طيب باخر سؤال بسالك
ا احدى الصحف المدافعه عن بشار الاسد على
الفيسبوك رسمي سوريا على شكل مراه سوريا
القديمه على شكل مراه سمينه وسوريا
الجديده على شكل مراه نحيفه جدا وكاتبين
تحتها عن سوريا الجديده سوريا هيك احلى
يعني مطلوب اعاده سوريا الى 7ب ملايين
الاستلام منحافظ اسد كما قال لك في
البدايه كيف ترد انا ارد عليك واقول ان كل
القوه التي تؤيد بشار الاسد تعتبر ان
سوريا هي 23 ميون نسمه ان سوريا هي
بمساحتها كلها لا تقبل باي تفرقه سوريا
كلها مع النازحين النظام السوري مع
النازحين حزب الله مع النازحين وتحيا
سوريا تحيا سوريا
اذا كان النظام السوري فعل مع النازحين
ليذهب وينز معهم لياخذ بشار اسم ولاده
وينقع بالراس سوريا تنتهي مشكله النازحين
ويعود النازحين الى سوريا اذا نزح بشار
الاسد بس حتى اذا نزح السوريين رح يجيبوه
بوعدك يا دكتور ورح نقعد انا واياك اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الكفا عن هذا لم يبقى لنا الا
نشكر يفينا الدكتور وفيق ابراهيم والسيد
لؤي المقداد نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل
فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل القاسم يحييكم من
الدوحه الى اللقاء
العافيه
هلا